so there's two people astray Dios meant
for one is for the type-a personality
were they're gonna watch this and see
what I never thought about this I
actually do a lot of these things here
myself and the other person that's meant
for is anybody that either dates a type
of personality works with a type a
personality or hires a type a
personality because the reality of it is
this type a personalities have a
tendency of building big businesses big
empires but they also have a tendency of
breaking a lot of things so today we're
going to talk about fourteen temptations
of type-a personalities so before I get
into today's episode if you're visiting
by attainment for very first time this
is the number one channel on YouTube for
entrepreneurs we have everything from
startup to selling your business to
hiring firing figuring out ways to scale
strategize how to deal with a business
partner how do you work with family all
of that stuff is on this channel here
you can also find some interesting
interviews that we have on value ten
minutes also if you haven't subscribed
please do so let me get right into the
episode fourteen temptations of Type A
personalities number one winning at all
costs doesn't matter what it is I don't
care about breaking the rules I'm
willing to break the law to win so those
regulations laws that are in place I'll
cross the line to be able to win I don't
care
so compliance is not being looked at you
know regulatory issues not being looked
at investment into attorney is not being
done investment into compliance is not
being done because I don't care what's
gonna happen it's winning at all cost I
used to compete with several guys that
were willing to compete at all cost and
they did in the financial industry what
wasn't good for the client they lost
their license for a decade they took
away their 660 326 because it was
winning at all costs it's so tempting
for type-a personalities but this could
waste a decade of your career if you do
that so number two being overbearing
what is overbearing overbearing to me
it's working with somebody that nothing
gets ever good enough suck oh my gosh I
just did what you told me to do it's
luck it's not enough yet it's not as
good it's not that good yet it's not
this and that's not that I don't know if
this is good and you're like what can I
ever do that's gonna place you but this
is actually an area that investors MVC's
NP firms like because they're willing to
go certain level of expectations that
others are
willing to go - let me explain to you
I'm in a real Patty McCord the former
chief talent officer of Netflix of 14
years she worked directly with Reed
Hastings helped the company go from zero
to a hundred fifty billion dollars she
tells the story of the day they cross a
million users on subscribers to Netflix
she says our chief operating officer
comes and says guess what our CMO comes
and guess what what we just crossed a
million subscribers
you know Reed is there she's there
everybody said oh that's awesome they're
jumping are doing all this stuff and
Reed stops everybody says listen this
was great you guys can celebrate but I'm
going for five million he says what we
just crossed a million I don't care you
guys can do all the celebration we want
it's off to five million are you out of
your mind neither at seventy eighty
million users worldwide what happened
there that's the overbearing aspect but
the part I want to make a point here
with the overbearing is there's
overbearing - building something big
that you're gone for then there's
overbearing or even day-to-day stuff
that people do right they don't get
rewarded or recognized for it that's the
part that's a little bit difficult
working with Taipei's if you're watching
as you're typing just keep in mind that
is an area that sometimes gets under
people's skin if they do something right
let them know that number three they get
bored very easily now this boredom isn't
just they get bored and they go do some
dumb stuff I'm not talking about that
the boredom I'm talking about it so you
come up with a strategy or
hypothetically you got the strategy that
you're excited about and you and your
board came up with it and here's what
we're gonna be doing right you got the
plan everybody's excited you put this
into action but after a month two months
you're bored out of your mind you change
this strategy again and you change it
again and you change it again and change
it again instead of adjusting you
massively change it again you're not
giving it enough time to create momentum
it's almost like this you buy mutual
funds say you buy stocks bonds you buy
real estate very quickly how to make
money on this sell it sell it next and
sell it next thing and you're like I'm
not making any money because there's a
part of it that's like you gotta allow
your strategy to brew and grow a little
bit when you're getting bored easily and
you changing stuff you're not letting
momentum come in your side number four
temper tantrums temper tantrums are very
common with this personality type
however maturity sometimes come sooner
than later for
I mean when you talk about Bill Gates
he's known as having one of the biggest
temper tantrums in Seattle everybody
knew about it they would say Steve Jobs
had a temper tantrum but some people
that work closely with Bill Gates that
his temper tantrums were horrible so
that's part of the type and now what
happens as you age and you mature and
you have a wife and kids and family
happens a little bit of that comes down
but it still shows up every once in a
while but you can have more control of
your type a number five this is a tough
one and if I could tell you there's a
reason why people stop working with
Taipei's if there have to be a number
one this is probably one of the top ones
here's what it is
everything good they do that happens to
the business they did it or they came up
with it but everything bad other people
did it they can't stand taking
responsibility and he said you know that
person right there dislike don't you say
something great happen you know that
whole thing and let you say somebody
else did and not them they will
privately go campaign to everybody and
tell him that I came up with that oh you
know it's really me you weren't in the
meeting but behind closed doors I'm
really the one that came up with that I
told him this but you know it's okay you
know it's okay it's okay then one that
miserably fails then guess what they say
did you see what happened with that I
told him never to do this I told them I
said it's not a good idea but they
didn't listen to me you know what it's
their fault if they would have listened
to me this would have never happened
that's the part about type-a that's the
manipulative sighs sometimes it's
extremely unattractive because it really
brings out their insecurities and it's
not fun to be around when you do do that
so if you do that just be aware this if
you work with the type a that does this
tell them to go watch this video
hopefully they'll figure the part that
you wanted them to get number six
escaping from reality Taipei's have such
an imagination where everything is
possible right I hope we can go do this
and we can go do that and we can go do
this that sometimes type A's escape from
reality due to them being bored could be
drugs alcohol too much alcohol because
they have to have an escape so oh my
gosh there's so much pressure when
you're building a business in your
startup on the entrepreneur or you're an
entrepreneur that there's got to be an
escape sometimes the escape ends up
hurting them and ruining everything that
they spend yours building just because
they want to have an escape this ends up
hurting them there's a lot of other
escapes you can have that doesn't
cause you to lose everything you got to
figure those things out for yourself
number seven neglecting help I will tell
you this one of the best advice I got I
was thirty years old and I met with a
few friends
and one of my friends sisters Pat every
two years as a 30 year old you should go
to executive health testing at UCLA
Medical Center there's got some good
ones in Minnesota or here in Dallas he's
got $4,000 and from morning till night
they take you to different talk doctors
they check your heart they check your
bone they check your check you for
cancer they check your liver they check
everything triglycerides cholesterol all
this stuff and you get a report so
here's your health here's what you need
to improve and there's the
recommendations if you're above 30 I
recommend you doing it every two years
if you're above 40 I recommend you
you're doing it everyone you're
especially if your heart charging your
health is gonna hurt you with a lot of
momentum a lot of times Taipei's just
kind of outs okay it's not a big deal
it's my teeth it's my health that's it's
fine I don't care
you got to really pay attention to this
this could really take momentum out of
your business number eight is sex here's
the thing with sex driven competitive I
want it all high testosterone level
comes with that it's with the territory
and a lot of temps like man I mean she's
so pretty and she saw this like even the
people that are saying this on Wattpad
you know you're acting as if you know
and everybody doesn't have the sex issue
everybody has to say I have the sex
issue I wake up in the morning up fires
up you know what I'm saying as any man
is like oh I'm ready to get into
something right it's men it's how we're
wired but also at the same time there's
a part of this that you got to control
their systems forward by the way
especially for those guys that are
married I have a certain system I've
taught hundreds of people that are
personally mentored it's not something
I'm going to put on video but I've
talked about it many many times you got
to figure out a way because this has
been a distraction for a lot of people
over the years hopefully you can figure
out a system that works for you number
nine one thing what's taking some time
this goes with number eight one thing
what's taken the challenge with wanting
what's taken is sometimes you take it
away from somebody that you are really
gonna piss off in a big way and that
person's vendetta is gonna be to come
after you could be yours but they're
thinking about you so sometimes at risk
of wanting what's taking I'm not telling
you
or don't you just know what the
repercussions are before you take
something away from somebody and by the
way keep this in mind when it comes down
to capitalism and the world of
capitalism it's about competition
whoever is able to wake up in the
morning go out there and you know do the
best to get the best product to them
that's competition but when I say
wanting what's taking is you know
somebody is married and somebody is this
and you're going and trying to take
something that's taken that's a lifelong
commitment from somebody to commit to
revenge to you if you don't do that part
right number ten looking down at people
this is a challenge sometimes Taipei's
behind closed doors would be like well
you know listen you know who I am you
know no one's at my level and that
feeling of behind closed doors is also
felt in open doors people are like man I
just when I'm around this but he's so
snobby it's so annoying like he doesn't
think anybody's better than them there's
a big difference between confidence and
arrogance when you start looking down at
people guess what people below you leave
to go work for other people that look up
and say I think you could be one day dot
dot dot dot dot even bigger than where
I'm at right now I think one day you
could be the CEO one day it could be the
CM I wonder you could do here for the
company then they keep those types of
people looking down at people is a tough
thing it hurts a lot of type-a folks xi
thinking they can outsmart everyone look
I got three kids I got a seven year old
son who's very smart then I tell him I
say says daddy am i smart
I said you're smart he reads books and
he can recite the sentences like stuff
that's just very weird how we resize
these sentences I said you're very smart
buddy but daddy's goal is to help you
start transitioning from being smart to
being wise wisdom is the reason why
people follow folks half their age if
somebody is wise no one says oh you're
only 22 years old I'm 44 I'll never work
with you people like to do business with
people who are wise smart is short term
wise is long term smart is
one-dimensional wisdom is
multidimensional so there's a big
difference between you thinking you can
outsmart somebody because here's a
reality of it as smart as you maybe
there's somebody smarter than you out
there but if you think wise you'll be
able to track smart people that want to
work with you sometimes if you think
you're the smartest person other smart
people don't want to work with you but
if you're wise smart baby can be Iranian
I'm working with this guy he seems very
wise the way I work with him I can still
have my own identity it works sometimes
that hurts them number 12 entitlements
hey because I've won in the past do you
know what I did in my last company look
at my resume do you realize Who I am do
you know my name do you know what I've
done in my life you want me to go and
start working from the bottom you're out
of your mind I'm never doing this one of
the reasons why I respect Arnold so much
is when he was done being a governor and
he went through his whole scandal he
wanted to go back into Hollywood they
asked him and they said so what do you
want to do with you going into Hollywood
he says what movie you're gonna do he
says I got to go out there and earn my
stripes like everybody else he says but
what are you talking about you've built
so many great movies he says I know but
I'm starting all the way from the bottom
again I haven't acted for eight years I
gotta win these casting guys I gotta win
the directors and the producers but I'm
gonna go out there and work and guess
what happened he came back up because
he's willing to earn it again number
thirteen they don't know when to stop
now this is a good and a bad thing right
because a lot of people say well on
doesn't know how to want to stop you
know the Krekorian the former founder of
the the owner of MGM he didn't know how
to stop ninety years old he's still
negotiating John would ninety-nine years
old you know you see some of these guys
they just don't know when to stop that
part is actually okay but sometimes
type-a personalities because they don't
know when to stop they also don't enjoy
the journey sometimes you got to be able
to stop and say pretty cool what we're
building here you know what I'm saying
like over here in the company a lot of
people will say Pat you know we cross
100,000 you didn't sell it we cross the
million didn't celebrate we just crossed
a certain top line revenue you don't
really celebrate we just crossed a major
mark you didn't celebrate yeah and
sometimes it's good to have people
around you say hey the board forced me
the other day divorce like listen hey
hey hey Patrick we have invested into
you you need to go take a few days and
take a break with you and your wife and
kids the board asked me to leave and go
take a break so I went to Breakers in
West Palm Beach had a great time right
outside a Marla go we had a great time
in Monaco for my 10-year anniversary the
board is saying call go go they're
telling me to go why because sometimes
we got to take the time on and say this
is pretty cool what we're building
Taipei sometimes forget to do that last
but not least
is overspending overspending gears
money's coming in I'm gonna buy this I'm
gonna buy that I'm gonna buy this I'm
gonna buy then nothing wrong with
getting yourself nice things that some
people on social media that make you
feel guilty if you get a Ferrari or
Lamborghini of this stuff if it moves
you don't let anybody tell you don't go
get him because if it moves you to do
bigger things guess what go get him you
know when Cuban made his first money he
want to bond a $500,000 membership to an
airline anyone who traveled all over the
world that was a driver to him you want
to cut a check in about a sixty million
dollar check that was a driver to him
can you imagine if it wasn't a driver if
somebody said it's not a good thing for
you to go out there and buy the Jets and
the cars what if I want to do it nothing
wrong with that but make sure you're not
overspending to the point where you
don't have the resources to keep your
business in business when tough times
come because when it comes it's gonna
matter how much liquid cash you have to
be able to survive the one year two
years three years of tough times you
could go with a business because ruckus
and market and a lot of weird things can
happen to market at any point if you're
not prepared you could be out of
business so those are the 14 temptations
now if you're watching this in st. Pat I
want to go a little bit deeper into this
topic I did a video once called 32
difficult personalities to work with in
business 32 difficult personalities to
work with in business I don't put the
thumbnail here if you haven't watched it
click on a thumbnail if it doesn't work
when you watch it on your phone go below
in the description you'll find a link go
watch that as well again if you haven't
subscribed it a number one channel on
you to please do so you got any thoughts
comment below thanks for watching
everybody take care bye bye